When the pandemic hit,...
...Jennifer, along with the Stockton -  San Joaquin Lions Club,...
...began collecting plastic bags for an environmental initiative called Bags to Benches.
People were having nowhere to take their plastic bags.
People were getting everything delivered from Amazon and lots of bubble wrap,...
...so we took that all in.
So we thought, that's a win-win.
We're protecting the planet and we're doing something good.
Partnering with local drop-off sites and recycling centers, the Lions Club got to work.
We go out, we pick up and empty those bins.
We have to make sure the plastic is dry and clean.
So if it's not clean, we have to wash it and dry it, have our own laundry line.
And through their efforts, Jennifer's team brought in 1,475 pounds of plastic,...
...enough to make this bench.
I couldn't believe it was actually here, that it had arrived...
...and I was thinking it might crumble under me because it was made from plastic,...
...but they're actually really nice, sturdy composite benches.
This instills in people that it's not waste.
It is a valuable product.
A plastic park bench encouraging you to kick up your feet...
...in an effort to reduce your carbon footprint,...
...for Jennifer, an effort she couldn't be more proud of.